this is a production of Cornell
University
we'll start out with welcoming everybody
and thanks again uh you know appreciate
everybody's patience for a couple weeks
we took off while I got to travel which
was which was nice and we're back at it
today and we'll be announcing whatever
the rest of the schedule will be we will
not be on tomorrow we have uh education
with our state park golf project and
then Monday is the walk and talk with
the gcsa and Y out at East Aurora
Country Club uh out by Buffalo with uh
Drew Thompson thad's uh brother so we'll
get a chance to look at some of the
renovations he's done out there and hang
out with some buffalonians and maybe
even have some uh beef on weck while I'm
out there now what I was out doing this
morning was looking at the frost I don't
know if you got down that got that down
there Ben we had 27 degrees at my house
this is what the Bluegrass lawn in my
backyard looked like uh when I when I
woke up this morning so this was very
alarming but
it sort of paled in comparison to the
absolutely spectacular views you get
along the northern Italian Coast I was
fortunate not to be where the rain and
floods were I guess the F1 race was
canceled this weekend right Carl so um I
was on the other coast over by Cinque
Terre or near Genoa and La Spezia we had
a lovely time wandering around this is a
a fortress in Port veneer that actually
served as a jail for Napoleon when he
went around pillaging Europe for a
period of time so
Carl I wish I had more to say that's
that's what I got for now I'm going to
save my conversation with Ben and the
weather in a minute what do you got for
decision support tools today yeah so
Frank I think sometimes we're uh we're
not great at telling people all the
things we do and and one of the things
we've been doing for the last year and a
half is is updating our forecast website
uh and we talk a lot about it on this
show we point people to our resources
whether it's the uh the dandelion timing
early in the year The Growing Degree day
information the disease forecasting
models uh but really the last year and a
half we've worked with the nrcc the the
northeast regional climate Center
updating this website the look and feel
the user experience and the whole idea
is that these are decision support tools
they help you make better decisions uh
you get more information equals better
decisions but really the the user
experience of those is a big deal and we
want to get you that information in a
quick and easy to interpret way so we've
made a couple changes here the look and
feel the website has changed uh the home
page we've given you some options now to
customize it so we know a lot of people
have maybe one or two data points or
maps that they like to use on the
website so on our home page now you can
pick up to four Maps select those on the
on the home page and it displays those
right when you get there so you don't
have to click four different times to
get two different Maps one of the
changes we made was really spurred by
the Smith Kearns dollar spot model uh
right we have our dollar spot model
which is which is based on Leaf wetness
hourly Leaf wetness but we used to
display it as sort of these dots uh
yellow for low or yellow for medium red
for high green for low
um but we really like that line graph
idea and and the way you can see Trends
more with a line graph versus that dot
system we used to have so we
transitioned to that with with all our
our disease models uh the anthracnose
Brown patch pythium so now you can see
the trends of those lines you can also
change the time scale which is one thing
we really wanted to include it used to
just be sort of the three days prior and
maybe a three-day forecast now you can
go all the way back so what I'm showing
on the screen here is is our model
actually had dollar spot risk uh ticking
up there in late April we had a couple
warm days uh not sure we saw any dollar
spot um so maybe that that model isn't
great at that time but it's good to see
that and maybe compare it to the Smith
current you can compare those two models
now they look the same so again more
information is going to help you make
better decisions and now we're gonna
have some new tools so we have this
runoff risk tool that's now on the
website we pulled this from Michigan and
Wisconsin have this for AG so these big
AG operations which store manure they
have to get rid of that manure and the
edges of the season and they have this
tool that uses soil saturation to tell
them hey here's when it's low risk to to
apply that manure you're not going to
run off and create water quality issues
uh so we work with some folks at NOAA
the nrcc and said hey could we could we
use this for Turf and fertilizer
applications pesticide applications and
they said yeah I think we can use that
we tweaked it a little bit so now we can
we can have this for Turf you can
forecast it out so if you give we can
see the map here Frank if we look at
just today right low risk for the whole
state not a surprise we we've been very
low in soil moisture or maybe even
getting a drought in certain places you
look a day ahead okay maybe there's a
little spot in the North country that's
going to get some rain and then hey on
Saturday it's looking like maybe an inch
at Oak Hill we're going to get some
widespread rain I think in the Western
New York up in the north country and you
see that runoff risk go up right and I
think one of the reasons we envision one
of the things we see Frank how people
are going to use this tool is you have
your spray days maybe it's Monday or
Thursday or whatever being able to check
a couple of days out okay my day's on
Monday hey it's Friday what is the
runoff risk looking like okay am I going
to lose this application is it does it
have a moderate or high chance chance of
running off hey I need to communicate
that with with my GM my membership and
hey maybe we need to move things around
a little bit to get the best efficacy
and most importantly to preserve water
quality right we don't want this running
off and into our water bodies so using
this tool
uh to sort of plan those applications
and then maybe the transition into some
of the stuff with Ben today is the
growing season progress and how we're
displaying that information
um so now we're sort of listing uh
Growing Degree Days up at the top you
can see the forecast for the next couple
days might be important if you're
looking at things like ABW crabgrass
prevention but we've got this little bar
here this little tab show seasonal
graphs uh so this is really cool this
sort of contextualizes uh the season uh
for those who can watch the red line is
this season
uh the black line is the sort of the
20-year normal and the green line is
last season and you can see we're
actually in a pretty similar spot right
around normal this year compared to last
year compared to normal but we've gotten
there in really different ways for our
location we sort of accumulated a lot of
Growing Degree Days early in April This
Is 50 to Growing Degree day uh uh
information and then we were very
stagnant for almost a month whereas last
year we were very low below normal for a
lot of of the spring up until probably
the second week in May until we really
started accumulating Growing Degree Days
so I don't know if you look at something
like this Ben and maybe it sort of uh
explains why we're seeing some weird ABW
stuff but
um you know we're at about the same
Growing Degree day uh number as we were
last year in normal but how we get there
seems to really matter when you start
looking at ABW migration and you know
Frank we always talk about when is a
growing degree day a growing degree day
that's right maybe this stuff helps us
explain some of that a little bit more
yeah and I gotta tell you Carl it's it's
that this big pause is is one of the big
questions I I got for you today Ben but
I will say it was cold it was a cooler
than normal week that we just came out
of that while I was away I was here in
70 degrees it was beautiful everything
was good I come back it's 80 degrees
when I land in JFK a and yesterday was
like an October day it didn't work I
don't think it got warmer in 45 46
degrees uh even though it was a
beautiful sunshiny day we've been on the
cool side but you do see along the coast
it's been warmer and that's been
reflected in the soil temperatures right
I asked Art this question this morning I
hadn't looked at the weather stuff yet
and you can see that the soils are
warmer obviously to the South uh into
the high 60s even out where you are Ben
you may be pushing into the 60s but
we're still into the 40 into the 50s
here in central New York which has got
to have you know a big effect on a lot
of the development of biological
organisms and it has been dry uh it's
been really dry this last couple of
these these last couple of 10 12 days
very little rainfall and I think when
you look at it you can really see you're
two inches behind uh in this big wide
swath cutting through the central part
of the Northeast and there is some rain
coming and unfortunately Corcoran and
the boys all those Penn State boys you
got up there Ben corkin and the boys are
going to be squeegee and stuff if they
uh if they if they get it the kind of
rainfall that they're talking about it's
going to soften that place up and that
that can be a long tricky golf course
and I know that Rush is that Rush is
luck the the rough is Lush boy I've been
gone for too long so this rainfall is
really going to kick start a lot of
things particularly as the heat starts
to return Maybe by midweek we're hearing
we'll see a return uh to normal
condition so Ben
here's what I remember you saying this
year there's two things you talked about
I've been following online one is it
looked like the adults were out early
where you were it's you started to see
them early uh there was a lot of
triggers early in this vein where you
were looking and then it started to
spread up The Valleys uh you know into
the Pioneer Valley where UMass is and
Olga's and up where we are uh and so now
everybody's got their adult decides out
probably by now Peak adults has probably
passed in most places but let's talk a
little bit about what Carl uh mentioned
earlier and let me go back to the slide
because it's so great how does this
bottom graph here this early surge of
heat is what was your sense is that what
drove these things going early because
it wasn't everywhere that it happened
like that yeah I mean I think what a
great intro uh hit on all the high
points that I was thinking about Carl
well done there uh in in fact on my
other screen I have all our weather data
pulled up so I'm glad that you guys went
so deep into that and I've been
furiously taking notes Here uh it's
really like we've had a couple of
seasons in one uh just for the first
generation so uh here you know and very
much stratified across the region too or
New York and we see this it's almost
like the Southern Tier border uh it's
really like a different Zone almost and
that played out very much so this year
um we're getting down into the southern
Zone you know Pennsylvania and along the
coast I thought that was a brilliant
synopsis as well as that's where we're
seeing the greatest divide between the
eastern part of Pennsylvania I was just
at Wilmington Country Club on uh Tuesday
uh it's a different world down there
they're moving along pretty fast
um it was a really really fast start to
the season and that early Movement we
saw possibly February in some places in
the south of Pennsylvania uh and even
into March in Pennsylvania I'm not
really too concerned about that
um I I love that you guys focus on this
stuff because let's not make it harder
than it is these are yeah it meant it
out these are organisms that are tightly
cued into things like temperature but
you know if you're an insect that's
native to temperate North America
you're probably not only tied into
temperature but there are probably some
other indicators like day length that
will tell you hey now's not a good time
to come out because we have these fall
Springs uh so
it is a little bit like am I eating
crazy pills uh you know this is the same
thing every year and the big thing that
I feel in my job is telling people not
to freak out and not to spray these
things so
so quickly
um in regards to the beginning of the
year well it's it's here's what I've
noticed Ben I'll I'll interrupt and say
Mo I think people that have had a hit
places that have had a history with this
problem
would rather be early than late they I I
wish more people scouted
um because even I will say and it's not
a knock on greencast greencast was
saying you know this and that and then
we people were saying I got tons of
weevils and then I called carlone he
can't find any on Long Island he's got
none in the rough so it also is very
site-specific right without a doubt and
I'll go out on a limb and I think way
too many people sprayed way too early
because I will say that that first
application uh through much of the
region again this is Child's Play This
is simple stuff it let's not make it
harder than it is and even if you didn't
do anything other than look at plant
phenological indicators you would have
been fine
and yet what we're seeing is those first
two applications in the greencast so
that would be a Delta side the second
one I'm not too concerned about because
it's the Acela Prince spray and they
would say it's really for white grubs so
my thinking is you know why would that
be in the Weevil track anyway I think
it's a great service yeah yes the number
one monitoring tool that people well in
your blog posts are great all you guys
that contribute to the blog things there
are just really informative and and to
to Second your note you don't have to
make it that complicated a lot of you
guys are doing a lot of this stuff
saying Now's the Time to go look find
some spots make up a soapy solution this
isn't rocket science it's a little bit
of soapy water pour it on go change the
cups come back and take a look and see
how many you got now in the past Ben I
know I had you on the podcast a long
time ago when Beth Page with their
pyrethroid resistance had moved to a
primarily large side program and I know
you were saying at the time this was a
sort of a sex thing to do and and could
be risky but now I feel like everybody's
tuned about this has changed a little
bit that maybe larvicides are becoming
more of the focus of some of these
sprays what say you about those that
miss the adult aside or didn't use the
adult aside to get an effective
larvicide treatment because I bet yeah
urbansky at Wilmington's already made
his
oh yeah I mean I think this is where
you're so new york-centric both in that
comment and both where you are in the
season you guys are so far behind yeah
uh I think there's a lot of pressure on
guys like Rob farentino to move his
sights along but Rod's saying like no
we're not ready there and I think some
triggers were pulled early and Rod was
pretty much overridden on these things
so that's the inside baseball ah I will
say this the first two applications came
really fast and people are waiting like
now that we've had one and two let's
pull three and I've had to push back on
that same we're not seeing that in Ohio
we're not seeing that in Pittsburgh
State College in Pittsburgh are probably
closer than I've ever seen them before
Harrisburg my Far Eastern site is
probably the first of the salon and if
you go east of Harrisburg it's like
night and day so like that that overview
of what's happening on the coast is is
dead on uh correct so are we at bigger
risk how how worried are you now still
about larva side only program
a little bit concerned I think this
might be a year in some places where you
could get away with it one I think you
got to look back to what happened last
year severe drought I think populations
in general are very very low uh I think
everywhere outside of New York we've got
some new products that have been making
a big impact there's more of them so we
can rotate a little bit better uh it's
really kind of moving into minor pest
status in my world to be honest on the
properties where I'm at uh they are
pretty much non-existent to low uh
unless you you really kind of you know
haven't paid attention or got antsy i i
i primarily feel and I in my heart of
hearts Frank I pray for a wet hot spring
I need destruction I I really we've got
a lot of projects going with ABW on it
that our graduate students are doing
that are really fascinating but it's
like uh I think we're in kind of a glory
period of great products flexible
products now New York totally different
animal so what don't we have here you we
have ference and I hear guys singing the
phrase of ference that seems to be a
real go-to product for a lot of guys
that have moved into this uh larger side
approach yeah I think uh fairings is is
definitely a top top product it's
something that I would have on hand uh
everywhere else has to Prada which is a
new product it's an insect growth
regulator uh so we've looked at it over
many years Super flexible as far as
timing whether uh I it's really affects
the insect as it goes to Malt so it
should be alarmed aside but when we put
it down anywhere between adult Peak into
uh this time of year in Pennsylvania
Rhododendron full bloom it's really
Dynamite as far as uh control so really
flexible so it's hard to screw up so I
think that also plays well in our world
because what I see is we use these
Regional monitoring tools and we look at
the South and see what our peers are
doing in the transition zone and then my
people are always like hey is it time to
spray it it's like no just wait wait
um so farence is fairly flexible uh
Soprano's even more flexible so you
think we're gonna get it is that you
think there's an obstacle to New York
labeling it or is it just really just a
matter of getting the package together
and getting it submitted because I got
to believe they're going to make some
money on that product in New York yeah I
mean we hear
um
gremlings of uh whether it's going to go
through or not I don't foresee it uh
being much of an issue it's different
from our traditional neurotoxins so uh
you know humans mammals don't have a
kindness exoskeleton so when the insect
goes to molt uh if it's come in contact
through ingestion or or contact with the
the cuticle it basically weakens their
cuticle so it's going to take some time
for that insect to die but
um you know I I don't know I think the B
data looks better than most normal
toxins the low mammalian toxicity looks
good I really don't know what the holdup
is so it's a growth regular like what
Merit
no it would be more like um the one that
you might be familiar with would be Mach
II halifenicide yeah so that was like
the late 1990s and that went up against
Merit which was less selective against
the other white grub species so Mach 2
halifenicide was really good
um you know it could be considered
bioreational in my mind uh but it was
just it seemed to hit some species and
not others so so speaking of biorational
um civitas comes up you published a
paper on it just a note about using it
uh as a strategy incorporating with your
other chemistry I I don't think it's
something you're going to rely on alone
um but it probably is something that is
could be a component a good component of
your sprays yeah I mean I think uh we've
got several projects going on
um right now in I have one of my
graduate students looking at a
synergists uh pyrethroids I think that
there is something there uh with the
civitas we've seen great activity with
civitas in the greenhouse trials and
laboratory trials if we can you know
basically coat the insect with it or get
it into their body it seems to bang them
up this is really hard to do those
studies with adults in the field when
they wander quite a bit so you got to
hit them right it's got to land right
and it doesn't really lend itself to
doing the small plot research trials
that you and I do Frank so
um you know if you hit it it might move
into the other plot yeah
uh so unless we were doing like wide
swaths which is more anecdotal than
scientific
um that's going to be really hard to
show but we feel quite confident with
that
um oils are good just that you could
spend a lifetime a career on looking at
oils and their effects on insects uh
we've kind of moved more into looking at
uh pyrethroid synergists with wetting
agents so one of my graduate students is
finishing that up and we basically took
a a full class approach you know I write
to my colleague Mike fedansa and say you
know he had published this these are the
different classes that we have in turf
grass and we just screened every class
and we have I've identified like several
classes that have a synergistic effect
against resistant insects well this is
good because they're using wedding
agents anyway right and so what we think
is we're pretty close to it we looked at
whether it suppresses the enzyme times
that are responsible and it doesn't seem
to be the case so I think it's just
delivering a higher amount of that toxin
into the insect uh so by reducing the
surface tension yeah basically you know
that's how you got to get these toxins
past this waxy cuticle that the insect
has that's naturally repellent so it
might be doing that so let me wrap up
the annual Bluegrass Weevil stuff uh I
got one more big topic to chat with you
about but
um Red Sox Yankees I noticed it no well
you canceled on me on the week that we
flipped over you guys I know I know and
what is it the world isn't right when
the Red Sox and the Yanks are in last
place but here's what I can tell you I
was told a long time ago by some smart
people yeah put Bank grass in annual
Bluegrass doesn't eat annual Bluegrass
Weevil doesn't eat Bank grass and now
I'm hearing more and more reports that
it's pretty doing pretty well on Bank
grass and they can be I always I mean
the paper I read was they don't
reproduce as effectively right the
fukunda that is down where is the
thinking among you entomologists on how
this organism might transition to
becoming the creeping bent grass Weevil
yeah so that's a that's another one of
my PhD students Audrey samard she's been
working on a USGA funded project looking
at why is Ben grass so tolerant
um I don't know if it's really reduced
fecundity I think they'll lay as many
eggs it's just something with the larvae
that they don't seem to develop as well
so what she's been looking at
phytohormones uh the response that the
plant makes kind of looking at the
differences between annual Bluegrass and
creeping Bank Grass how do those two
things differ and so we looked at the
big phyto hormones you know salicylic
acid and jasminic acid uh and it looks
like you know so jasmodic acid is what
we typically think in the entomology
world as being elicited in response to
chewing and sex where salicylic acid
might be a pathogen or a piercing
sucking insect and our thinking was you
know this is a stem bore so it's
probably fooling the plant to overcome
this and what we see is uh you know
nobody's really looked at this with
insects um you know the defense
responses other than like endophytes so
this is pretty novel work and it looks
like creeping bent grass just starts at
a higher level of uh jasminic acid what
we would expect to be naturally
resistant to eat insects so she's
looking at field studies of applying
these different things the interesting
thing about Paula is it has a lot of
salicylic acid but you know it's not
something that we think of being as
overly disease resistant you know it
gets hammered so that's an interesting
one there so you're not seeing when you
have a okay let me just be for bansky
let's use John as an example at
Wilmington he's probably got Bank grass
and Bluegrass uh you know Kentucky
Bluegrass or tall fescue and creeping
bankrupts everywhere right does he have
Weevil problems on his Bank Grass does
he have to spray like he's got annual
Bluegrass I mean big of a deal I think
you would see specs I mean you do see
annual Bluegrass here and there and
maybe the insect prefers those little uh
areas but I think that's also once you
move into that environment and you're
having less and less annual Bluegrass so
you're gonna be forced to eat on
you know something and it will and it
will and it definitely will and uh you
know I can say that I was at a pretty
big facility in Ohio
um this spring who tried to use it as
poet reduction and uh you know they
don't recommend that do you you don't
recommend it I definitely do not
um it's interesting my old Lab at
Rutgers has been promoting that for
years yeah yeah I think it's just uh
they will
you know adapt so that's the you know
the other thing that Audrey's working at
is you know what's going to happen as
this insect moves South will it develop
in and we've challenged uh you know
perennial rye and Zoysia and uh Bermuda
grass so we're we're trying to
characterize the nutritional contents of
all of those plants as well to see how
will they develop so that's really
important work Ben I mean I think uh
Andre's got a lot it's just these data
sets are massive I think that's the only
problem that we have well and I would
say the data set's going to get even
more massive because it looks like the
spread of this organism annual Bluegrass
Weeble range is spreading as the
climates are changing uh but I cannot
listen we only got a few more minutes
and I wanted to spend more time on worms
because you created a little kerfuffle
uh on the on Twitter a while ago where
you were saying sand top dressing was
actually leading to increasing worm
populations on putting greens if I
recall
well I mean we do uh our research on
Fairways uh research Railways so okay
yeah I mean that's pretty I I feel
pretty confident in that and uh you know
saw it with her Southern earthworms as
well so doesn't that contradict the work
in the Pacific Northwest
yeah I mean I think you could look at
several studies that contradict that so
I don't think we're the first to to
really show that but what are your
thoughts here what's what's going on
yeah so uh you know you get like you
probably get these uh papers that come
through your email uh and you know you
have different alerts for things and
this earthworm paper came through my
email uh they kind of explained it I
thought it was kind of an aha moment
because we always thought that putting
down sand uh led to increases we'd see
increases for you know one to two weeks
after casting if we looked at it the way
a pathologist looks at area under the
curve it was significant increases year
after year we conducted it in the same
plots for over a three year period
really covid shut that one down uh but
you know we had pretty much seen that by
then uh I thought it just irritated them
I thought uh it diluted their food so
that they would have to consume more
soil to get that organic matter out of
the soil uh and therefore casting more
in this paper that came through my inbox
was like
um pretty good evidence for some related
species uh that sand in that grit
actually enhances the digestibility case
of the material so you're talking about
a different species
uh yeah I mean Lumber kids so they would
be within the same group you know in in
Europe and they were basically looking
at where they were uh and then doing
these uh mesocosm experience experiments
where they had different uh soil types
yeah and increasing that sand content in
the soil led to more casting as it
allowed them to digest would it be
related okay here's what I know from the
workout West they use cheap mason sand
that's really angular because it's
oftentimes used to make concrete right
and I'm wondering if sand shape is part
of what might be going on for as an
irritant because you just mentioned food
source obviously
you know you get a fair amount of
organic matter in sand it does dilute it
but the plants can be happy if you give
them enough water and nutrients and
there's a lot of macropores for them to
explore it is a diluted amount of
organic matter but it's still organic
matter and I'm wondering if angularity
of sand matters
yeah I mean we can see it on the extreme
and Chris Williamson did that work at
Wisconsin years ago where he looked at
coal slag and that's super super Jagged
and it did lead to reductions I I kind
of Wonder one sourcing how you'd get
that to every place and then two do you
really want to have a whole bunch of
broken glass in yourself wow okay all
right so so what are you recommending
that's
true
spot go out there with dial Fanning
though uh well there I mean it's really
tough uh you know we had a project last
year where electro shocking them from
the soil
um you know that company's a small
startup and I'm sure you've had many
projects like that well we got Led
Zeppelin we play we play Stairway to
Heaven oh that's right that's right yeah
the acoustic thing uh so yeah I think I
you know I like that idea unfortunately
with like a lot of these startups that
come to you you know it's like they
might disappear the next year so I I
gotta revisit with them maybe get out to
Washington State and and we do see that
it uh you know we kind of proved the
theory but we need to do trials with
that to really so the saponins as far as
you know are off the table we're not
going to see them back on the market
anytime soon uh there are still saponins
on the market
um there there's one product that's
still available and I don't how do you
like it uh yeah I mean they're effective
uh you need to have sequential
applications they definitely do a job
they're expensive uh you need a pretty
good rate per acre yeah they're
definitely effective I do think like the
the the key and you know I'm trying to
figure out how I can get Ireland in
September to do this study but I I
really do think it's a survey of the
soils I think the Next Generation much
smarter people than I am you know the
people I train
uh and push around money for it and
don't get to do the research I think
that the Solutions in the soil these
organisms require you know a symbion
basically bacterial Partners to help
them digest so do we want to go that
route and nuke everything in the soil
just to get rid of earthworms it might
be playing God a little too much but I I
think it's really kind of the approach
that I would like to take and that I'm
proposing is really kind of like what
they've done with the mlsn and doing
paired sampling of these abrupt changes
and you will probably see that if you
walk enough turf or you have casting and
it immediately stops in the same type of
uh you know area like yeah you're
definitely I can tell you you see
pockets of these things and it's not
always explained and I get the time I
get some time out at Laurel town uh golf
club out in Eugene Oregon with Will
right Wilburys oh yeah Will bets is the
best yeah Will Benson and and and uh he
has a really
he yeah I mean he's he's great and and
we've talked a little we played Winter
Park nine down in Orlando uh oh good uh
for GIS Will's awesome and yeah uh you
know he we had talked to uh some
molasses stuff so he he's into the
Alternatives yeah yeah I had to break
his heart about the Molasses with yeah
okay so so last thing then we'll wrap it
up Carl uh thiophenate methyl Ben but
there's talk of it being restricted uh
I've heard I've heard yeah and it's you
know I've heard some people say yeah
don't worry about it you know it's a
good summer patch product you might only
have to use it once but a lot of us know
we use it for other reasons
um many guys are making multiple
applications of this we are likely to
have restrictions that could be an
impact right yeah yeah I mean I I think
we we really need to kind of move away
from those things and unfortunately
there's not a whole lot of people who
work on these things
um uh you know and I do think the
solution is probably in the soil that
being said I think there's a lot of like
companies that are claiming things uh
that aren't exactly true based on be
careful what we see as far as
nutritional products because
um if you're feeding the soil it
shouldn't have a deleterious effect on
earthworms number one so I'd be very
skeptical of those products but um you
know we've been looking at kind of it
doesn't reduce them but it can
ameliorate the conditions of the casting
like things like um you know we
recommend punching a solid time in the
Fairway just give them a cylinder to
shed in basically so you know like that
seemed to be highly effective through
the winter time uh we got great pictures
of that it looks like this Rich casting
material in the in the channel you don't
need to pull the plug and clean that up
so you know maybe we've looked at
scarifying that doesn't seem to have a
big effect I think they're too sensitive
to vibrations you'd have to really chop
them in the act so uh you know it's not
a great solution but it it can help with
the smearing a little bit uh but you
know how many times can you get out
there well we gotta you know we got uh
we got one Golf Course superintendent
Steve Curtis at Tuscarora a really solid
guy president of our gcsa and why
um he's created a window uh of uh play
yeah what is it Carl in the 10 to 10 10
30 range or something he's got I think
he's got an hour of blocked tee times
right after one of their leagues so it's
usually slower play so what what he's
done I think it's around 10 to 11. he's
saying hey we're gonna go mow dry we're
gonna drag it drag the clip drag the uh
the castings and then go mow it dry and
that's basically the solution he's
looking to try and I love it I think
that's a that's a great idea I think you
know my dad's an engineer I have him
trying to build different brushes and
stuff for weevils for Weevil removal and
stuff like that and uh you know I have
an idea but I don't know if it's
mechanically possible but Ben you know
yeah listen Carl we're way past you got
a great question or should we let him go
no no I wanted to hear the
electrification stuff so I think we got
through that all right good Ben thanks
so much for taking the time it's always
great to see you pal yeah awesome to see
you guys uh I love your Maps I wrote
down all these notes here about ah great
uh they're yours they're always yours
awesome appreciate it Carl great seeing
you again I guess we're off for a little
bit we'll get back with everybody on the
Monday shortcut email right yeah and
then I think we'll do a couple more
shows Frank so we're going to expand
that I think this was supposed to be our
end date but you know we missed a couple
so uh we'll give you some more extra
credit shows right the very least next
week and then hopefully a couple after
so uh for now take care everybody uh
enjoy we'll see you next week thanks a
lot Ben awesome thanks guys thanks Ben
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu